she's tougher than ten Krogan hide more
reliable than a drells memory the nippy
ER than a hyperactive silurian she's
your new favorite scout rover she's the
nomad
[Music]
[Applause]
right that's quite enough of that
if you've been longing to razz around
alien landscapes again since the
original Mass Effect the Nomad is here
to fill that Mako sized hole in your
life it's an all-terrain vehicle with a
lot of hidden extras including turbo
boosters vertical thrusters and the
ability to switch between four wheel and
six wheel drive at the touch of a button
in four-wheel mode you'll move much
faster perfect for powering through the
vast open flats of planets like eos once
you hit an incline however it's time to
switch the six-wheel Drive to make that
climb a doddle the Nomad also offers
protection from hostile environments
letting you explore unfamiliar territory
without fear of radiation poisoning or
severe frostbite it also provides quite
the advantage if you come across any
unfriendly aliens foolish enough to open
fire on you if you're going to craft the
best gear you're going to need minerals
which is where the nomads inbuilt mining
computer comes in very handy open it up
to locate area's rich with mineral
deposits then launch a mining drone to
do all the hard work for you those
minerals are also essential for
developing mods that will make your
Nomad even more formidable locate or
earn blueprints on your travels to
improve every aspect of its
functionality including agility defenses
suspension and thrusters and if you're
more concerned about how your ride looks
head to the Nexus and chat with the
vehicle merchant to spend your hard
earned credits on brand new color
schemes one sport you can apply your
sweet new paint job from the loadout
screen just don't get so wrapped up in
pimping your ride that you forget to
find a new home for Humanity because
that's pretty important too happy
driving
you